[Музика]
y'know some derived Reyes Angus
kazakh Yosef justo Miyazaki olimpiadas
гомеопатія schematic for
[Music]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської мови,
мене звуть Наталія Ешкомб,
почнемо, я хотів би привітати свого дуже
дорогого гостя сьогодні,
привіт, Метт  привіт Антонія, як справи
сьогодні я добре, дякую, як ти я
фантастичний я готовий до уроку я
готовий
давайте почнемо скажімо, ми продовжуємо розмову
про спорт і я хотів би запитати вас,
чи подобається вам спорт, я люблю спорт a  багато,
я грав у футбол
майже професійно, але це була моя одна
з моїх найбільших мрій, дякую, наш останній
урок був про футбол, на жаль, у нас
не було вас у гостях, тому це було
б дуже приємно, так що давайте
почнемо дивитися  на картинці, а ви, хлопці,
спробуйте знайти якомога більше видів спорту,
так що макс, що ви бачите
я бачу футбол я бачу бокс я бачу, як
сказати, що це не боротьба, це цей
, ні, це коробка, і я думаю, це добре
безсила влада л  Якщо з цього приводу
, він плаває, займається
художнім плаванням, так, а як
щодо цього, як прокинувся той фігурне
катання,
хлопець на дошках, і це
якась хвиля, я поняття не маю,
що це таке віндсерфінг О віндсерфінг,
так що  про це подивіться на
цю перерву це художня гімнастика
ну танцюйте моя сестра була в збірній
України Вау що-небудь ще
тоді я бачу гандбол добре теніс
добре
баскетбол фантастична боротьба мм-хм
біг добре а що ще
волейбол так давайте подивимося на
це було це поло верхової їзди так, а
як щодо цього,
це настільний теніс настільний теніс добре,
ви коли-небудь пробували ставити так, мені це дуже подобається,
так, добре, ми продовжуємо говорити
про спорт, і я хотів би запитати вас
про
риболовлю  розглядати рибалку як вид спорту я
не думаю, що це спорт я думаю, що це
просто для деяких людей це приємно
витрачати час мм-хм я бачу добре, зараз ми добре
рибалити добре, так що це добре, щоб бути
грою добре  так, я думаю, я можу витрачати
свій час так, мабуть, насолоджуйтесь своїм
часом так, добре, але я сказав, що приємно витрачати час,
витрачаючи приємний час з вами, добре, так
уявіть, що у нас не може бути справжньої
вудки, уявіть, що це моя
вудка
бачимо, це липка рука, і
це ваша риба, яку вам потрібно зловити, тому
ви збираєтеся ловити так, вам
потрібно зловити рибу, добре, тому я даю вам
нову, це моє, а це ваша
на випадок  звідси так, добре, це
буде справжня рибалка для вас, тож давайте
спробуємо, тому вам потрібно зловити хоча б одну
рибу, давайте спробуємо, ви можете спробувати вдома, просто
візьміть, наприклад, слайм і спробуйте
зловити папір, який ви кладете поблизу
добре, так спробуйте зловити це добре
[Оплески]
так, це підводне плавання, снорклінг, чи можете
ви пояснити нам, що це означає
підводне плавання так, коли ви просто пірнаєте в
деяких масках зі звичайними
киснем і азотом, і ви плаваєте
і отримуєте задоволення  огляд визначних пам'яток під
водою гаразд, так що ви, хлопці, де  також описано
підводне плавання з маскою, що це означає для
вас, ви пам'ятаєте, що носите гідрокостюм,
ласти, окуляри і трубку
, тому це називається підводним плаванням, добре,
давайте спробуємо ще раз добре
йога, як ми можемо добре описати йогу,
хлопці, я спробував одного разу, добре, і ви  знаю, я
думав, що це дуже легко, але я
недооцінив цей вид спорту, я
б сказав, тому що зазвичай ти знаєш,
що жінки зазвичай це роблять так, ти
добре думаєш, що це легко, ти знаєш, якщо
дівчата можуть це зробити, я теж можу це зробити, але
коли я спробував  багато розтягування,
багато розтяжок, так, і
я думаю, що це важко зробити, тому я думаю, що
це дуже хороша вправа, і для деяких
людей, наприклад, вони поєднують її з
медитацією, так, це дуже добре ця
самодисципліна, особливо коли люди
роблять це вранці, наприклад  коли
схід сонця і 5:00 ранку
мм-хм на гарному пляжі чи щось таке, я
колись так робив і мені
це дуже сподобалося так, я згоден,
і йога насправді вважається
найздоровішим видом спорту, давайте  оберіть це,
тому що ви прийдете до себе, ви
робите саме те, що можете добре,
тому давайте спробуємо третю
спробу, третю спробу, добре, так що три це гарне
число,
добре, так що це
хокей хокей давайте поговоримо про
обладнання, що ми робимо  потрібен хокей,
нам потрібні ковзани, ваги, добре, нам потрібне все
це спорядження, я маю на увазі, щоб захистити
себе в шоломі шоломи палиці, стейк,
я думаю, так, так, і те, що ми робимо, ми
називаємо чорною річчю, яка не є м'ячем, я не
знаю, як це  називається англійською, але я
впевнений, що наші студенти знають, що
нам знадобиться для хокею ключка і
шайба,
саме це називається шайба шайба так
добре дякую, ви можете
покласти вудки всередину, щоб потім насолоджуватися
риболовлею, тому  Я підготував
для вас ще кілька спорядження, тож дозвольте мені зробити
трохи магії тут,
щоб, як ви бачите, у мене багато обладнання,
чи ви знаєте все це, я
думаю, так мм-хм,
тож давайте почнемо з найбільшої частини,
що це таке  маленький це
шолом для  r бойові мистецтва так, які
види бойових мистецтв роблять, як будь-які види
єдиноборств, наприклад, це може бути коробка з
написом білих привіт бокс кікбоксинг
може бути лише для того, щоб взяти одне, хоча
саме так ви називаєте всі слова
, які ми маємо  я вже вчився
з нашими студентами. Я дуже добре знайомий з
цим. Раніше я чудово займався тайським боксом,
тому дозвольте мені вибрати
бокс або кікбоксинг кікбоксинг
кікбоксинг дозвольте мені записати це
кікбоксинг добре зроблено,
що це для катання на лижах і просто коли ви робите
ось це катання на лижах, що це за
сноуборд, так, це примітно.
так,
це go-go для плавання або
підводного плавання, і це ми можемо назвати
маскою або окулярами, а також для сноуборду,
добре, так, давайте зі словом, чи
можете ви прочитати ще раз, будь ласка,
окуляри  фантастично пам'ятайте, що це не Google,
це теж маска, але
це дитяча.
правий бік так точно так що
це може бути маска для підводного плавання
дякую
так це Oracle так так трубка
добре давайте запишемо світ
трубка з трубкою добре що ще у
нас тут є м'яч що це за м'яч
це  футбольний футбольний м'яч
американці називають це футбольний так
, вам подобається, це неправильно, звичайно, я
люблю це так, ви з самого початку згадували,
що ви любите футбол, добре,
я напишу футбол, це
цікаво, тому назва
спорядження футбол і назва  спорт - це також
футбол, так легко запам'ятати
футбол для футболу добре
розкажи це Амери кажуть американцям, що це
футбол для футболу, тому що у них
є яйце, що це, це стрибки зі
скакалкою Рамос робити preneur скакалка  добре,
то дозвольте мені написати тестер мотузки, відкритий
цим словом, і ви пам'ятаєте, що нам
потрібно для хокею
ah yes gates skates and
[Music]
pack a stick, stick in
the pack a shack yeah fuck yeah BAC k pu c OB uck okay
палиця і добре шайба добре, а тепер
давайте разом з нами напишемо диктант,
тому ми використаємо ці
слова, які ви пам'ятаєте з попереднього
уроку, щоб у нас було одне два три чотири
п'ять шість сім слів, які я буду рахувати
від одного  до п'яти,
поки я рахую, ви оберіть одне слово
і запишіть його тільки одне слово, будь ласка,
і коли я скажу п'ять, ми будемо говорити
свої слова, а ви уточнюйте з нами, тому я
пишу, що максимум пише, а ви
пишете ми"  у вас буде три слова,
і насправді твоє завдання полягає в тому, щоб вгадати в моєму
слові
миє його партію була команда о так,
лава баккара хто б не був ходо п'ятті
з пасео де Люсія непарною сіткою чи б
ви отримали шість живих однаково випадково, але
дуже дуже  IMO, так що якщо він потрапить на моє слово,
ви отримаєте одне очко, це
легко  ну макс, давай, у нас є сім слів,
тобі потрібно вибрати одне добре, і коли я
скажу п’ять, ти скажеш мені свої
слова, які я також напишу
.  прочитайте слова, щоб
запам'ятати слова King бокс-окуляри для підводного плавання з трубкою,
футбольна мотузка,
паркуйся легко, тож ходімо я вважаю, що
ви виберете одне, носіть його та запишіть,
давайте підемо, запишіть, не забувайте один
два три чотири п'ять, так що ваше слово
так  моє слово, вибачте, не дуже з тобою, але
якщо ти здогадуєшся, що у світі є одна
точка для тебе, давайте спробуємо ще раз
так, добре, давайте так, один два три чотири
п'ять,
яке твоє слово, ебать, моє слово - шнорхель,
вибачте,
не дуже,
але якщо ви вгадаєте слова  у вас є два
бали, тож давайте спробуємо минулого разу
добре, один два три чотири п'ять
окулярів, тож три очки дістануться вам, якщо
ви написали їх Гоголя, у вас також
є три очки, тому якщо у вас був один
бал тут, два очки тут і вперед  йде
три бали, скільки всього балів
Браво шість
і, на жаль, позначки, у вас є одна
загадка так, вибачте,
життя несправедливе, але одного разу я забив три
очки так, це дуже гарний крок.
Я хочу, щоб ви написали з нами
текст, у тексті є деякі прогалини, так що ми
йдемо  щоб заповнити пропуски, і це
насправді найгірше, що нам потрібно для
тексту, ви не можете побачити текст, тому ми будемо
гадати, тому, хлопці, ви збираєтеся писати
з нами, будь ласка, запишіть десять чисел
від одного до десяти в  колонку і слідкуйте за
нами з усіма словами, які нам потрібні, я
збираюся написати свої слова на дошці для
вас, тож давайте, номер один - це
прикметник, тож чи можете ви придумати
прикметник будь-які прикметники красивий
красивий добре, так що ви запишіть свої
слова я напишу свої слова, тож якщо ти
скажеш красивий я піду зі
світом розумний ти красивий і
розумний добре номер два число від десяти
до двадцяти давайте зробимо це сімнадцять
сімнадцять прямо під тебе 17 я збираюся
виберіть 13 добре номер три будь-який
номер сім сім я збираюся піти з
це робота номер один
пілот добре, ти можеш придумати
щось цікавіше, ти
пілот, вибач, ворона, сідай добре, це
буде юрист, юрист, фантастично,
тому ти юрист, я буду добре,
я вчитель, але дозволь мені бути  гімнастка
добре гімнастка не професійна
гімнастка нехай це буде моєю роботою добре,
так номер п'ять, ще один прикметник ну
це буде чесно цікаво
я виберу цікавий ти запиши
чесний так що це означає чесний
цнотливий мене правильно давайте  перейти до спорту номер шість чи
можу я вгадати твоє слово футбол ах
[Музика]
так футбол все добре, прямо вниз
футбол я напишу гм
сноуборд добре, що буде
наступного року мм-хм будь-який я б сказав 2014 добре
запишіть це
я  gonna go way 2005 okay я думаю
щось на кшталт сковороди трубка
та маска, корона книга будь-що на зразок
автомобіля добре запишіть машину я збираюся йти
з олівцем добре шматок одягу
взуття черевики добре, гм, я піду
гідрокостюм і останнє - їжа риба
нормально  так, для мене піца
виглядає як хороший обід,
так що готовий прочитати текст так, добре,
хлопці, підготуйте свої десять слів, ми
починаємо текст, тому я хотів би, щоб ви
прочитали текст, і він мертвий, це
замість ваших пробілів  я збираюся читати ваші
слова,
привіт, мене звати Макс, мене звати Макс,
яке твоє прізвище, макс красуня,
я розумний Palio, так що мій
урок добре, так що давайте почнемо знову, я
не можу цього сказати, але це ваше слово,
це ваше слово  дурний текст, не хвилюйся, але я
пропущу його, добре, гарно,
давайте змінимо слова, ти будеш
розумним, я буду красивим
чоловіки зазвичай кажуть красивий, не
красивий, правильно, але чи ти
гарний, це добре, так, ти будеш
розумним, давай добре, так що мене звуть
Макс розумний, добре, мені 17 років, я
відомий, я відомий пілот, який я
Грав сім років, але до цього
я був професійним юристом  було
цікаво добре я думав, що ми змінили
це добре ей я люблю спорт і я
добре в цьому футбол
фантастичний я роблю це щодня з 2014 року,
кажу про професійне спорядження
зі своєї спортивної діяльності я завжди ношу
машину в кишені, мабуть, так добре
і взуття  фантастично немає тренажера,
так що з автомобілем і взуттям, а не кросівками,
це цікаво, це максимально добре, і
після того, як я закінчив урок спорту, я
зазвичай їм рибу, тому займайтеся спортом, їжте
здорову їжу та вивчайте англійську, тому
що це розумно, добре, тому дозвольте  я прочитаю мій
текст, все буде інакше, тому мене
звати Наталія красива мені 13 років
я відомий вчитель я
викладаю рік о,
насправді більше, але до цього я була
професійною гімнасткою о, я так пишаюся  тому
це було цікаво, я буду використовувати те
саме слово, що я люблю спорт, і я добре
катаюся на сноуборді, гм, я роблю це щодня з
2005 року,
кажучи про професійне обладнання для
моїх спортивних занять, я завжди ношу
олівець, чому б і ні,
поки сн.  owboarding дуже важливий, і
що має, ммм, це не
спрацює так, після того, як я закінчив урок спорту,
я зазвичай їм піцу, ой, це
нездорово, займайтеся спортом, їжте здорову їжу
та вивчайте англійську, тому що це
красиво я скажу дивно, тож давайте
зателефонуйте рокові текст, давайте запишемо
справжній текст, макс, будь ласка, виправте
інформацію реальну інформацію про вас,
все гаразд мене звати Макс, мене, привіт, Люк,
так мені 34 роки, і я відомий,
я просто пілот  я літаю вже
дев’ять років, зараз добре, але до
цього я був професіоналом, я робив багато чого,
що хотів би, але все одно так, о, моя мрія
полягала в тому, щоб бути професійним футболом,
це було прикметники цікаво о так,
це був дуже хороший досвід це  був
неймовірно гарний я люблю спорт і я добре вмію
можу сказати футбол я роблю це щодня
з восьми років
фантастично так, насправді, раніше, але я
грав у команді, оскільки я завжди говорю
про професійне спорядження зі своїх
спортивних занять  де  якщо ми
говоримо про футбол, приємні бутси та мої
улюблені
шорти, ага, добре, після того, як я закінчив
урок спорту, я зазвичай їм трохи
вуглеводів і білків, добре, це
приємно з’їсти снек-бар здоровий снек-
бар
не насправді я просто намагаюся їсти
звичайна їжа, яка в значній
мірі чиста добре kenny banana work так звичайно
так так, банан може працювати після спорту
закінчіть речення займайтеся спортом їжте
здорову їжу та вивчайте англійську мову, тому
що це дуже дуже корисно мм-хм
дуже дякую найкраща миша Макс добре це
Буде домашнім завданням написати
про вас справжній текст, але перед цим
давайте зосередимося на прийменниках, подивіться, у
нас є чотири перед на сцени і після
давайте розберемося до і після, яка
різниця між цими двома речами, макс чи
можете ви мені допомогти перед і  після того, коли
ми використовуємо ці речі, добре
зрозуміло, перш ніж використовувати для чогось, що
сталося до певного моменту, і після того, як ми
використовуємо як наслідок, добре, говорити про
те, що вже сталося, нехай  я
допоможу вам,
щоб у нас був час, Клайн і давайте
проведемо акції так, наприклад,
футбольний матч або тренування, або ви запустите
щось будь-яку дію, тому до цього часу
папуга той самий папуга те ж саме до цього часу
перед футбольним матчем, перш ніж я приєднався
до команди  перед тим, як я піду до школи, папуга
подивіться, а після цього
ви робите те, що ви робите, коли закінчите виконувати цю
дію, так папуга біп ісла
до і після добре,
яка різниця між,
наприклад, як ви можете пояснити це для
ладану мм-хм, але вони"  майже
добре, якщо ви говорите про час мм-хм,
я літаю, наприклад, п’ять років,
і вони я займаюся футболом кожен день,
тому в цьому випадку ми говоримо про
певну кількість років добре період
правильний період або просто  кількість так
період років, я думаю, добре, так що
період часу в роках мм-хм, і з цього
моменту ми починаємо так майже
з якогось віку, у моєму випадку це було
вісім років, коли мені було вісім
років  I вул  я умів грати у футбол у команді,
але якщо ми говоримо про те, що
я граю у футбол з тих пір, як я себе пам’ятаю,
так з восьми років,
тож давайте ще раз приділимо час.
початкова точка, так що
значення початку ми говоримо з того часу
з 2005 року з понеділка, наприклад,
з зими добре або з тих пір, як мені виповнилося вісім років,
і коли у нас є початок
і кінець періоду, тому ми
маємо закритий період, ми почали, і ми
закінчили, тому ми говоримо чотири, так що це може
бути протягом п'яти днів протягом п'яти років протягом п'яти
місяців, наприклад, будь-що
початок і кінець це добре,
і фраза я добре, тому ви не можете
сказати, що я хороший  футбол правильно, так,
це просто фраза, яку ви повинні
пам'ятати, я добре в чому ще добре вмієте ви
в чому ще я добре в шостому
класі, так, але все одно я думаю, що я
добре володію всіма своїми хобі, тому що я
насолоджуйтесь ними, мм-хм,
все, що стосується спорту
і я вважаю, що вивчати мови - це
приємно, мені також подобається вивчати іспанську,
і тому що раніше у мене було багато
студентів з Південної Америки, і
це чудово, що мені було приємно з ними розмовляти,
і в той період свого життя я
почав говорити доброзичливо  іспанською, але не
розмовляю, я б сказав, що почав вчитися з
іспанської я пам'ятаю тільки бачу, а не добре,
тому тепер настав час для невеликої вікторини,
давайте відповімо
на перше запитання, яка
різниця між чотирма та гріхами, ви
добре пам'ятаєте, так що подивіться  знову
з початкової точки та для закритого
періоду, яка різниця між
до та після
оцінок добре ще раз, чи можете ви перекласти ці
слова для студентів так, тож до настання
крапки та проти після,
можливо, так, тому коли ми відчуваємо, що перед тим, як ми
закінчимо та після того, як ми  закінчіть добре, тому
все ваше завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб
написати параграф про вас і ваш улюблений
вид спорту, використовуючи прийменники
до і після, і я чую, як
дзвонять інструменти th  Нам потрібно
припинити урок, дуже дякую, Майк,
тобі дуже сподобався урок, мені дуже сподобався урок
, дуже дякую за те, що я був тут
інформативна ніч, так, бумер-магазин, який
спостерігає, як ви входите в Інтернет, який
ваш дохід нижчий від астми сіндзі
[Музика]